l a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono falli j
quello che fai video quello youtube è
proprio lui ragazzi non è un po che
volevo fare questo video perché allora
esperimenti incredibile no sono finite
gialle due stagioni è stata finora la
serie che sul canale mi ha impiegato più
tempo perché esperimenti incredibile
ragazzi ve lo dico a parte il fatto che
costa farlo perché c'è una troupe c'è
tutto tutto il set che vedete tutto il
set constant costa botto far fare gli
esperimenti a gente capace prima di vero
così costa un sacco e porta via un
bordello di tempo quindi in tutto questo
tempo quante cose sono successe che voi
non avete visto faremo uscire altre due
serie volevo ho deciso di fare un video
un po per farvi capire quali sono i tipi
di bloopers che succedono nel mentre che
registro esperimento incredibile cioè
non tutte però un sacco di parti
tagliate gli esperti critiche che vorrei
commentare con voi perché voi non avete
idea delle cose che succedono allora
adesso vi faccio vedere che schifo una
farfalla c'è scritto il kit di farfalle
è viva
allora gliela spiego perché fa troppo
ridere loro questa parte è stata
brutalmente tagliata perché a me faceva
schifo ok
loro mi hanno dato un capo di kit che
hai dentro ci sono delle larve di
farfalla città delle larve ok io devo
far crescere le farfalle io dopo il
primo giorno eterno ragazzino
a cagare tutti no però vi faccio vedere
il più perché questa parte è stata
registrata però abbiamo tagliato perché
alla fine non abbiamo fatto però che
schifo che salivo no il cucchiaio
diciamo ora di aprirlo ragazzi in se ti
fanno cagare gli insetti ok se la
farfalla beh carina però che schifo se
la palla dentro non c'erano non si
vedeva ancora niente perché già solo una
una boccetta stupida però loro vendono
sto kit di farfalle esiste
effettivamente non li ho ancora visti
c'è però c'erano fidatevi qua dentro
questa terra sono dei bruchi
[Applauso]
ragazzi io vi devo spiegare cosa è
successo ho richiesto non si capisce
semplicemente mi sono spaventato dei
miei capelli
io stavo cercando sti caz di bruchi che
non li trovavo nella nella scatola nella
terra non capivo erano ancora dentro la
scatola proprio e io stavo cercando di
capire dove diavolo fosse un nei mesi
come i capelli sono voluminosissima lo
stop di otto carico un capello ha
toccato la mia mano mi sembrava che un
trucco mi stesse camminando sulla
braccia loro fatto così ragazzi da
adesso fermi
allora io adesso giuro su dio io lancio
una challenge
io adesso mi metto in the script qua
sotto in descrizione trovate il link
ok per scaricare questo pezzetto di
video questo frame boileau scaricate c'è
il link per scaricarlo chi si intende un
po di editing video mi fa assolutamente
un editing dove mi mette qualcosa di
bianco che mi spaventa perché non c'era
niente mi sono spaventato i miei capelli
quindi mettetevi di fianco quel caso
achille lauro qualcosa che di fianco io
mi spavento tantissimo in video e io poi
faccio un video reaction dove guardo
tutto quello che avete messo che mi può
spaventare di fianco vi prego perché
bellissimo fate questi video e metteteli
su instagram tagliandomi con hashtag
spaventa kartoffeln giu lo farò una
reaction a tutti i vostri video quindi
mettetevi fianco qualcuno che mi
spaventa fatelo perché bellissi fatelo
vi prego bellissima bellissimo comunque
allora ragazzi qua nick è venuta a lui e
nick bello
le televisioni che pancho iscritta in in
pancia mi sta dando una mano perché
effettivamente a parte gli faceva schifo
ma non è tanto io sono molto schizzinoso
germo fobico sono baco da seta fobico
quindi lui mi sta dando in questo vento
una mano ma non solo per quel motivo mi
saranno vano perché non si capisce
effettivamente cosa bisogna se bisognava
fare in questa situazione perché
comunque tu c'era st ciotola tutto vi
prendete quella blu che sta qua
dovete plate dovevo durate un gatto
dovevo prendere i bachi metterli qua
dentro e mettere il cibo qua dentro e
votare che loro sopravvivessero
all'inter
la morte intemperie e poi ficcarci
dell'albero ho messo tutti i dati qua
dentro e poi i varchi andavano
trasferiti ho preso la scatola andava
messa praticamente nello sfondo qua che
vedete perché l'obiettivo quale ragazzi
era di ogni episodio di esperimenti
incredibile i bachi man mano crescevano
fino a diventare farfalla
così era un esperimento negli
esperimenti capito il problema è che noi
facciamo schifo e idolo tenere io devo
darli da mangiare quel pongo strano non
l'ho detto lavezzi gas e non abbiamo più
fatto niente questo è stato
l'esperimento con i bachi da seta è mai
riuscito io poi ho liberato i banchi con
il pongo nella foresta quanto è bella la
farfalla con te brutto alba con tanto di
dio ma siamo ragazzi invece a un altro
esperimento che è andato nel
dimenticatoio
c'è lorenzo quali è oramai ha made in
internet fantastico tra l'altro questa
nuova pratico perché voi tutte queste
piccolezze voi non lo sapete neanche
quelle spiego
lo vedete che in esperimenti incredibile
ogni volta dietro ci sono sti cosi che
ribollono e la val è che questa
cristiana qua che una sana
che ficca dentro levano le boccette
dell'azoto ogni volta registriamo li
deve fare sto giro per mettere ste robe
un casino come fare questa cosa
dottore aprire uovo e inserire
all'interno scherzare sapevo neanche
l'esperimento ma perché ho aperto nuovo
mercatino a scusare dottore essere a
questo concitato dove avremo riferiremo
interno e li fai mettere dentro
raga non mi entrava inter per me io le
volevo aprire non potevo non potevo fare
altrimenti ma posto comunque ragazzi
questi erano i bloopers di esperimenti
incredibile gli ultimi volevo ricordarvi
quindi fate scaricate volo in
descrizione mettete qualcosa vi prego
che voglio voglio fare assolutamente
reaction voi non avete comunque idea di
quanto sia difficile registrare negli
esperimenti che vive perché c'è tanto
lavoro dietro tantissimo tanto lavoro di
script regia valentina che fa cose che
mi spero mi sia piaciuto dovevo farveli
vedere perché dai non sacrifichiamo i
bachi da seta per nulla almeno il video
che stanno bene cioè non mi mandano le
lettere perché
liberati in una foresta pro immagino che
stiano bene nel loro habitat che ne so
io vi sia piaciuto iscrivetevi a creare
non perdetevi prossimi esperimenti che
usciranno appunto sul canale che saranno
una bomba vera serio dei vestiti siete e
noi come sempre ci vediamo per un
prossimo video bella ragazza
[Musica]